まさき出ねぇな
もしもし
はじめさんすか？
はじめ）りょう君なにしてるの？
はじめ）え？暇なの？
りょう）うん
はじめ）ちょっとじゃあ3人で俺ん家に来てほしいんだけど
りょう）大丈夫っすよ
はじめ）ホントに？ちょっと渡したい物があってさ
じゃあまた
はーいお疲れー
やべー来たぞ
皆さん香水知ってますでしょうか
僕もそんな使わないんすよ
僕もそんな使うようなタイプじゃないんですけど
男ならこんな、ちまちまスプレーみたいにシャッシャやっててもダメなんすよ
もっとこう堂々と
体全体に香水をつけて
もう匂わせようや
な？
もう1,2プッシュぐらいでこうなんかこうやってさ
こんなのやっててもダメなんすよ
男なら落としたい女がいたら
全力出そうや
それが男ってもんだろ？
というわけでチマチマつけてても
やっぱ気づかれないんすよ
今回はねテストです
僕はねもしこれが実証されたら
是非ともなんか女の子と会う時に使いたい
香水全部使ってあってすげー良い匂いしたら
ひょっとしたらモテるんじゃねぇかと思いまして
今から後輩3人家に来るんで
ちょっと実験してみましょう
良い匂いすぎて男でも
恋に落ちるかもしれない
いやー危険な賭けだな
下手すりゃ掘られｒ...
これ、僕ね、あるはいいんですけど
減らないんすよ
使わないから
これさー、なんかバカッといけないもんかな...
ダメだ。シュッシュッするしかないようだな。
香水まずっ！
匂いはいいんですけど、まずいなー
拉致があかん
あっ、来たんじゃねこれ
あ、来た来た来た
このこれくらい出てくれればね
一気にいけれる
いける　ガンガンいこう
換気！
全部使いきりました
やべなんか呼吸ができない
良い匂いじゃない
あの全部使った結果
僕の感じ方なんですけど近距離すぎてすごい苦しいんですけど
これからターゲットは普通にプッシュで使うよりも
良い匂いがするかもしれません
ではターゲット来るまで待ちましょう
どうぞーウェーイやばい
くっさ　くっさ
おええええええええええ
出よう　出よう
頭おかしいよ
ゴホンゴホン